[Music]
interesting news this is absolutely true
today is national orgasm day or as
Anthony Weiner calls it Wednesday I kind
of feel like orgasms don't need the help
you know I don't know it's their use
they're pretty good on their own you
don't need them you know
goose them up a little yeah well they
actually has a day there's no worry I
didn't realize there was a day there's
an orgasm day
a new poll just came out and it says
that most Democrats think that Anthony
Weiner has basically lost his mind
Weiner said the important thing is I
haven't lost my phone
[Music]
that takes a lot of work to really get a
good one sure does well you know I get
nine from him a day and he's like what's
the big deal speaking of sex scandals
everyone's talking about you know Wiener
running for mayor we've got our own sex
scandal brewing right here on the west
coast let's talk about that the San
Diego mayor who is accused of sexual
harassment is now asking the city to
cover his legal fees yeah yeah when they
refused he said okay fine come get the
money it's right down here in my pants
pocket this around I've done that before
I got your money it's right in there go
get it
Winter Olympics in Russia this year and
there's already a controversy I don't
know if you heard a Russian official
recently announced that gay athletes
attending the 2014 Olympics there will
be arrested as they said yeah this is
good news for the world's three straight
male figure skaters yeah they just Vic
seriously
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're done no competition today on
Nevada parole board said OJ Simpson
could be granted early parole
yeah Oh Jay said he's looking forward to
getting out and showing today's NFL
players how to really murder someone
there's a right way and a wrong way al
Qaeda made an announcement al Qaeda
announced that they will try to free the
inmates at Guantanamo Bay
yeah because nothing helps you pull off
a prison break on a faraway island like
announcing it ahead of time it's a good
plan
yeah this is what we're going to do
we're tunneling it's not a tunnel
there's a new car true story new car
coming out from BMW that's partially
made from hemp partially made from hemp
yeah it's the only car in the world that
people actually hope catches fire part
of their 4/20 series
folks
[Applause]
I'm singing in Sangin huh
that curtains really down with the kids
lingo oh yeah I actually have no idea
what I just said is this about those
funny jazz cigarette it certainly is all
right
speaking of pot Justin Bieber's tour bus
Justin Bieber's tour bus was stopped at
the border and police found marijuana
inside yeah Bieber said oh come on if
that were pot wouldn't mind music be
better
[Applause]
Cornie that's my new move in between
jokes right a slight robotic back up
slowly back away from what you just said
yeah
according to a report there is a small
town in Florida were half half the
population is made up of sex offenders
good schools though
[Applause]
[Laughter]